hey everybody welcome to another episode
of ERISA theory I'm Kelsey cook and
today so excited I wanted have this
guest on for a long time you ever never
Ryan Sickler ah thank you very much
that's about all the clapping is gonna
happen in here today yeah I know Ryan
from his amazing podcast called the
honeydew also his former podcast the
crowd feast both favorites of mine I've
been lucky enough to be her favorite
guest on bow you know it's so fun I had
your former podcast co-host Jay Larson
on for the first episode of risk of fury
he was episode one episode number one
yeah do you feel like you might do
better than him what was his best oh it
was bad I mean did he get maybe like two
goals
look I woke up today knowing I was gonna
get my ass kicked okay I can't there's
very few times I've walked into
something knowing I'm gonna get my ass
handed to me so I have some self goals
upset little just at least get one on
you I don't want to shut out I went to
high school at these two kids these two
Korean kids that came in they were
exchange students from Korea okay Carlos
and Eddie Co okay but they were Olympian
ping-pong players from Korea they're to
play in the Olympics Yoshi and we would
play him in gym all the time and the
only thing we could do was try to get
one [ __ ] point
one [ __ ] point if you got one this is
it I'm having trauma right yeah oh I'm
so I'm so excited to see what you can do
when I worked I was in college I worked
at UPS shoutout the UPS Baltimore hub
primary one Jo Avenue you recited the
address I started as a driver's helper
during the holiday season and the driver
got injured so this younger dude that
had just graduated college I was
starting he just finished he was a
foosball player now he is no you he was
no hall-of-fame foosball player but he
held his own two dead Freddy's you know
he how does a dead Freddy some towels
yeah let me ask you why is the pitch
bowed up in these corners but it's not
in these
there was that an advance it's on all
the corners is it yeah it's I think it's
an optical illusion okay I'm just gonna
make sure I want I want the ass-kicking
on a level playing field who's got a
level here is this a regulation table
nothing is gonna help me anything I'm
ready okay you start great first and so
also you start with the ball here
technically you're supposed to touch two
men wait a second and then move the ball
forward and none of this [ __ ] no no the
spinning all right we lied to Cosmo of
course every time you score is all right
yes so now it's been touched a bunch Oh
[Applause]
Lord let me get my Goldie ready here
you ready know what uh what position did
you play
okay look you've got a good defense
offense here that's a victory right
there that should be a [ __ ] point that
I just think I'm actually impressed I
was like I said on my push I was like oh
he's got a good little stance going I
just touch my peepee I'm so sorry that's
disrespectful you saw it you saw it is
there one up here too you saw it
I'm gonna give it a little middle finger
right there all right
hey I can say this honestly it's tied up
enjoy these moments while they last
now you just poke the bear [ __ ] who has
scored the most goals on you well Steve
Rannazzisi beat me no you beat me in the
second game because he could score on
either goal and it would count as a
point for him so he could literally just
kick it back right who legit no scored
the most I know
never been beaten by any of us probably
Dean del rey dean del rey was the best
player we've had on so far and how many
do you remember how many goals maybe
three that's it that's like high scoring
is three on you in a regular game yeah I
mean we also have only played if I cut
damn that was close
yeah I mean they they might score more
if we were going to higher but in a game
five all the way was that a legit spin
no you're fine I'm not supposed to take
my hand off is that another rule yeah
you're you're supposed to keep it on but
you didn't go further than you didn't go
further than a 360 my boldi back here
okay ready I'm ready
oh I knew it was coming now when you
said are you ready I was like this is a
goal from the backline not gonna lie to
you they're like Ryan do you want to
come at early or later I was like let me
take her when she's cold
well you should go and she's tired I was
like tired she's not gonna be tired
gonna be people in five [ __ ] minutes
I hope that I want the early get will
see that that should be a half point hmm
you waste no time I feel like a lot of
guys that I've brought on I kind of
they'll be like piddly with it they'll
just kind of be like doing this but if
you have it you usually know how to do
that is that for one Wadden get skunked
already see if I can't cut that lead you
already met your goal so yeah that was
more than the 360 yeah I mean can't let
go of it gonna [ __ ] what happens when
you don't oh I just give it to you for
the goal
okay well I got one I feel good about my
dog okay I'm done bye got goosed I would
be really bummed about that oh well I'm
glad you got the one in sorry for
interrupting my guests getting destroyed
but I wanted to take a second and thank
my bookie for sponsoring this week's
episode of risks of Fury here on risk of
fury you guys know we love making bets
so I cannot wait to go on to my bookie
calm and place some bets for the
Seahawks did you know that my bookie is
the place to bet on football every
weekend
my bookie has great bonuses and some of
the best prop bets this year they're
hosting the first online handicapping
super contests first place is guaranteed
to win at least $100,000 and it costs
only $100 to enter all you got to do is
pick five NFL games against the spread
every week to climb the leaderboard and
score your share of the huge cash prize
pool my bookie has live in game betting
on every NFL game they've got an insane
amount of player perks and if you love
fantasy sports you can even bet the
over-under on how many fantasy points a
player will score each game for our fans
my bookie is offering double your first
deposit up to $1,000 by using the code
wrist
that's my bookie my Bo kie and don't
forget to use the promo code wrist when
creating your account to claim the bonus
bet win get paid thanks again for
watching and make sure to hit that
subscribe button for more risks of fury
round now what's next I've seen you do
[ __ ] like I'm handcuffed and I'm
blindfolded yeah and I'm gonna be
outside still [ __ ] with so you come
over here alright so draw one just
anything five okay and I got four okay
so yours is that you get to start with
two points okay so you get two point
handicap right away right if you have
the ball here I have to step away from
the table
only on this row that person only on
this row okay anything else I'm playing
and then I can shoot yeah okay so we'll
see how this goes
it's still to five mhm okay you ready
for this yeah I was ready as I'm gonna
be alright okay right now you can't
touch this
and damn it it was out there see I'm
drinking the whole time at the bar
instead of learning how to play this
[ __ ] Oh another save damn it I should
have passed I forgot that rule already
listen I don't know how many saves I've
had but oh that's me oh is it yeah mmm I
would like saves tally does I feel like
I'm in the save department doing some
what alright it's pretty good D
everybody in the comment section freaks
out every time I'm like oh good D it is
hard I don't know why I'm even bothered
move my guy right out of [ __ ] shift
over like that did see you touch it a
certain way and you moved it where it
probably should have been and I should
have paid attention to that they gotta
have strong wrists Oh son of a [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what I call it a solid you know
what I'm gonna cheer like I did that
dammit dammit I feel like I score at
least once all myself
every one of these matches now oh I do
get a habit from here cuz you don't
technically have it okay ready I'm ready
yeah three though I got one okay what's
the next ass-whooping
is that it no so now this is where we
talk about the punishment oh yeah here
we go first when you live I mean look
I've done a lot for you I've done makeup
let's hear what this is good well we had
Jay Larson on the reason that he had the
punishments he did is because we reshot
to you ahead of time we were like what's
the dirt on Jay I'll reach out to Jay
and I'm like this is your chance to get
revenge so what's gonna happen if you
lose when you lose is that you have to
eat imitation crab with dog bone
sprinkled on it dog bone well that's
just a running thing on the show that
lately when people lose you have to get
a milk-bone dog treat okay but you're
from Maryland yeah big crab
yeah you're a big crowd [ __ ] imitate
it's the hot dog of the sea why anybody
would eat that [ __ ] I have no idea so
you're gonna have to eat some imitation
crab with with some dog treat on it
Wow crab with dog food wha what Wow
there's three levels of this well I
wasn't expecting this Jay sent me a text
message this long I've just [ __ ] on you
of course he did so while you eat it I'm
just gonna read them to you and get you
in a real dark place what the stuff he
said yeah oh you're not gonna get me a
dark place what is my mom about the show
up and if she's not then we're [ __ ]
good a mob you back there you all flyer
in I need a favor alright one two three
go one [ __ ] touch to go it it's look
less than three seconds to do both those
go one two three
[Applause]
no it's a push a wash whatever you call
it in this sport but I got one you know
what though just for just for Memphis
are you I'm gonna put it halfway here
just so I know that I put one in on oh
it's gonna go back over here but but for
that's fine I'll let you do that I've
never seen somebody for my ego let me
have it
1 2 3 go my people are up god damn it
Chuvalo this makes me so sweaty
okay me too I'm sure my whole life okay
ready 1 2 3 go
mmm oh you got it on your on your
forward you back spin move oh that was
good good I'm sorry sorry to take that
I'm gonna walk away tell everybody I
played the best D you've ever had we let
that a fury believe what people know ok
you ready 1 2 3 go
yeah you see what I'm doing right I'm
just trying to break up your first ball
so I got it back
something else did you can i scrub out
those no actually can you see two balls
on this table with your little toe tap
on that [ __ ] I'm going any real
crab at a sushi place after this just a
wash that [ __ ] out of I'm trying into it
alright one two three go that's such a
weird thing you do you go it's not a
spin but you go from all the way around
Tommy this [ __ ] nice look at you
yeah they're all over haven't you seen
me do it yet nope I have not no all
right you ready
I I mean yes ready one two three go not
my guy out of the way all right here we
go
ready for that imitation crab I'm ready
my last game yeah when's the last time
an imitation crab I would have to say it
was someone somebody at a sushi place
fool me with it but I called him on it
right away I always say discharge me
extra don't put this [ __ ] in my sushi
garbage I think it's a really oh I'm
hanging in here right now I just don't
want to taste it yeah damn it
that happens every time I start to talk
[ __ ] Ramon you're getting ready for it's
the end and then it's common and then
somebody scores I was waiting for you
the same that would have been sure
that's a pornhub category okay someone
else between these two it goes back here
oh that's the role there that is you
know what else seems fishy okay just
need to calm down
let's get that crap okay oh I gotta eat
that whole bowl that's gonna make me
sick
no I mean just give it give it an effort
want that bad dog pinky just give it a
sec because that's what happens is the
comics you have honey then they take a
buddy like okay but like once that gets
going in your mouth
you try it no I'm question if is even
y'all just being nice it says no boom no
those are I'll read you the ingredients
have to word and you'll be horrified I
can't with it you're just like taking
that you know it's gonna be more
disturbing when you read me the
ingredients this tastes just like
[ __ ] Wheat Thins Starbucks
that's scary I'm all about water I got a
boat no but you gotta eat the crab sooo
which is more upsetting to you eating a
dog treat or eating crab imitation that
imitation crab is it really this is fish
it's like yeah oh I should down with
some milk Oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] right
there
I did not think you were gonna be more
grossed out by the imitation crab are
disgusting
first of all why is it orange right
there's no [ __ ] fish out there that's
even salmon and [ __ ] or orange okay this
isn't is that a salmon codon it's like
all ground up white fish and reading
some harfa with me right now
oh my god that's right oh my god you're
supposed to be tearing me up inside
okay so these are the things Jay Larson
these are wanted mean these are from
jail oh geez wanted me to say to you
just to like let everybody know these
are some low points in your life as you
how long to show it the highlight in the
lowlights honey yes he went in can I be
dark yeah
gave CPR to his grandmother and she died
I did happen but at my defense she was
dying when I started CPR and I did save
her for a little while to the medics got
there who gave her the stuff then they
took her off I believe that they're the
ones that did it
rob was a good start I was just fresh
out a lifeguard class I knew my CPR
mouth-to-mouth
yeah compressions they say you just do
it to the song stayin alive right you
know first I was afraid no not that one
that's a dead goddamn person there lived
in his car for a while did
how'd I see 90 Honda Civic with original
rims you wear compression pants when you
fly yeah I have to now it's that's
unfortunate I've found out I have some
weird blood disease so I'm the guy it's
got a [ __ ] stretch and [ __ ] in the
back on the planes now and after wear
pantyhose when I fly that is
unfortunately how many how much do I
need to eat one I have one my father
also the Orioles his home baseball team
absolutely sucks in house for decades
that's true to 1983 they won a World
Series I was 10 years old 96 97 we went
back to playoffs choked 2014 we're in
ALCS against the Royals I'm in the
hospital
my daughter's being born it's on the TV
up there and the only reason that I
wasn't bummed about not going in the
World Series is because I had my
daughter was born I ever had that yeah
you know subway makes a footlong of that
[ __ ] that's what you should have made me
all right so plug everything plug where
people can find you I'll say this milk
bones aren't bad number one milk bones
are definitely better than imitation
crab
you can find everything on Ryan Sickler
calm that's where you get my dates from
Ryan Sickler on social media the
honeydew podcasts your mom's house yeah
that's everything go follow me on
instagram at Kelsey cook comedy
Twitter's at Kelsey cook
Kelsey cook calm for tour dates
subscribe to self-publish podcast and
subscribe to the atc all these comedy
YouTube channel we got a bunch more
episodes coming thank you for doing this
thanks for kicking my yeah alright we'll
see you guys next time thank you guys
for watching another episode of wrists
of fury be sure to pick up your official
wrist of Fury shirts they are buttery
soft they feel like dolphin skin there's
lovely be sure to LIKE and subscribe to
the all things comedy channel and you
can get the shirts at the link below
free shipping
you